we're going to do one called what is money and
we're going to explain the concept of money
so people can understand it there are a lot of
misconceptions and misunderstandings about money
uh we need to clear them up because if
you want to understand the current cost
of living crisis and also the massive increase
in inequality over covid you need to understand
what money is so this is going to be super
important for the viewer to understand
very number one thing people need to
understand money is not real resources
um so lots of very wealthy people don't
actually have huge amounts of money they
have largely real resources money is a
separate thing we're going to explain that
now one of the reasons why money is confusing
is there are actually a couple of different
ideas around what money is bouncing around and
the best way to explain that is I think to go
through an example so let's imagine I've
got 1 000 pounds and you've got nothing
then I lend you for a week my one thousand
pounds how much money do you have then
it's an interesting question right because on
the one hand you've got a thousand pounds in your
pocket that I just gave you but on the other hand
you have a debt of one thousand pounds to me right
so you literally physically have one thousand
pounds but as an individual when you consider how
much money you have you should also consider your
debts right so if we consider also your debts you
you don't have any money you've got a thousand
pounds and a thousand pounds of debt but if we
just consider how much cash you have on hand
you have a thousand pounds the next question
is how much money do I have so I've given you
all my money my one thousand pounds so you
could say I don't have any money but you owe me a
thousand pounds and I'm going to get it in a week
so if we consider all of my money including
money owed to me I've got a thousand pounds
now most economists if they
looked at that situation
would say that once I've lent you a thousand
pounds we both have a thousand pounds
that's interesting right so once the loan
is made the amount of money is doubled okay
and I think this captures the complication we
have with understanding what is money because
some people would say if you have money but
you also have debt that you don't have money
some people would say well if you have the money
it doesn't matter whether you have debt or not
some people would say well if you've lent the money
out you don't have money and some people would say
well if you're gonna get.. if you have money owed
to you, you have money, basically is do I need
to have that cash in my pocket for it to be money?
do I need to have no debt for it to be money?
if I have somebody owing me money tomorrow do
I havemoney and the reason this is complicated is
most people's money is cash in the bank right
but actually when your money's in a bank account
oh the bank doesn't actually have that money
in many cases that's money that they owe to you
so there's a complication here about whether we
should include debt and whether we should include
money that is owed to you and I'm going to argue
that yes we should include debt and yes we should
include money that is owed to you and in a way we
have to include money that is owed to you because
any money you have in the bank account is money
that owed to you so essentially everything that
ordinary people think of as money with the
exception of cash is money that is owed to you
so these are the fundamental problems
in understanding okay and we're going
to run through it all so that everybody can
understand really clearly what is what okay
so the first thing I'm going
to say is as an individual
when I I ask you the question of how much
money do you have you should consider
all your cash most people don't actually keep that
much cash any money you have in the bank any money
that you have owed to you and also any any debts
that you have that is your total situation with
regards to money it doesn't really make sense if
you borrow a million pounds and you have to pay
that back in a year to say i'm a millionaire now you
have to include your debts it makes sense right
so as an individual you should include everything
so then why is it that economists don't do that
in order to understand that I think
we need to rewind a bit and go back
to the understanding of how money is created
because this is another story around which
there's some confusion so for example there are a
lot of people who will tell say to you when a bank
lends you money they don't actually give you that
money they just create the money out of thin air
um and I think that's quite
misleading and I will explain why
the only people who are allowed to print
cash and create money out of thin air
are the central banks so in this country (UK) the
Bank of England in the US is the Federal Reserve
In Europe it's the European Central Bank (theECB)
okay these guys literally can create money
nobody else can and we'll get later to
why people think not commercial Banks can
and the.. but central banks are
not allowed to give money out
so then if they're the only guys who can createmoney
but they can't give money out how do we have money?
and the answer is they loan money out, theyloan
money out, central banks only ever make loans
so they create money they make loans to Commercial
Banks you know Lloyds Bank NatWest other banks are
available um and then those Banks themselves
make loans so money gets loaned out but
what what that means is quite interesting which
means that all money originates as a loan now
since if you loan one if you borrow
money you always have a debt with it
that means that whenever there is money there is
also debt that means that if I add up the total
amount of money and the total amount of debt
in the economy it will always add up to zero
now this is a fundamental truism of our money
system as it exists in in this country in Europe
and the US in Australia most of the rich world
the total amount of money including the total
amount of debt always is always zero is always
zero and that that is important to understand
because if we know that then we also know that if
one group of people go into a mass amount of debt
for example mortgage holders or the government
somebody else must be accumulating money or credit
that is really important to understand because
that is it was that fundamental understanding that
enabled me at the beginning of covid to know that
okay well if the government is going to accumulate
£250 billion, £450 billion of debt somebody's
going to accumulate money elsewhere in the
system because we know that these two sides always
balance up it's basically an accounting equation
okay so this is the fundamental truism of
monetary systems as they are at the moment that
they always always add up to zero that's the
way that they're designed and that is because
money is always created by a loan and if the
only way to create money is to create debt
then these two things always aligned they're
always balanced so we know with 100% certainty
that the amount of money plus the amount
of credit is equal to the amount of debt
um now I've separated out there money and credit
when I say credit it means money you are owed
um and I think for Simplicity it's probably
best to say that anything you have other than
cash in your pocket is credit money having
the bank is money owed to you for example
and really it probably makes it easier to
understand the monetary system if you just
assume that everything is credit everything is..
it's just a balanced system of who owes money to
who who owes money to it there's always a balanced
amount of credit and a balanced amount of debt
fundamentally Whenever there is money
there is somebody who owes that money I
went over there is debt there was somebody
that money is owed to it has the balance
now this is a little bit counter-intuitive
and it's the reason is because people don't
think about money like that you know if you
have ten thousand pounds cash you know cash
in your pocket or cash in your bank you don't
think somebody else is 10 000 pounds in debt
you know you you as an individual can have
ten thousand pounds of cash without any debt
but it's not possible for society to have ten
thousand pounds of cash without debt because the
the way that the monetary system is designed is
that money is only ever created by the creation
of debt so they are always balanced and on a
societal aggregate level they're always balanced
now then that raises it an interesting question
of well if the total amount of money in society
is always zero does that mean the total ofmoney
is the amount of money in society isconstant
what about things like QE? what aboutthings
like the Central Bank cutting interestrates?
you know we hear at the central bankcan
change the amount of money in the system
and that is because what the central
bank can do is make more loans
so they can lend a lot of money into the system
so imagine imagine I'm a central bank and you
are the economy and I lend you a thousand pounds
you've got £1000 of cash and you have £1000 of debt
you're balanced but then whatI can do
as a central bank is I can lendyou another
ten thousand pounds now you'vegot
£11,000 of cash & £11,000 of debt
you're still balanced,but there's
more loans floating around and
once you think about money creation like
that you realize that in a sense anybody
can do that, if you remember the example that
we had at the beginning of this discussion Isaid
well if I have a thousand pounds you have
nothing and then I'd lend you a thousand pounds
in a way we've both got a thousand pounds, you
see what I'm saying? and this is worth sitting
and thinking about because this explains to us the
two different understandings of what is money one
of them says that whenever a new loan is created
both people have the money and that means Whenever
there is lending money is being created and one of
them says no you have to include all of the debt
and all of the credit and in that sense the system
is always zero does that make sense now this is
this is not super simple but it's important to
understand and the difference between those two
ways of understanding money are at the center
of so much argument of people on the internet
and it's basically some people say that
it's some people thinking in the sense of
you have to include all the debt in the system and
some people saying you have to include both sides
so if I lend your money we both have the money
now if you if you and this is the way that most
economists think about money they think when
I lend you money one thousand pounds now we've
both got a thousand pounds they think that
all money lending creates new money so if you
believe that all lending creates new money then
it is true that commercial Banks create money
but they only create money by creating debt so
Commercial Banks cannot change the fact
that the total amount of money always equals
the total amount of debt they cannot change
that and in fact nobody can change that that is
a part of the design of the system the monetary
system in Western economies in Britain in theUS
but because Commercial Banks can make loans
some people say Commercial Banks can create money
and it is true that say you went to Lloyd's Bank
and you say I want to borrow a million pounds
and they they accept your loan they will simply
credit your bank with a million your account with
a million pounds that is true and you might think
oh they've created money but as soon as you
try and spend that million pounds they have
to actually pay it out of the money that they have
it's a little bit like if I said to you I've got a
thousand pounds and I say I'm going to lend you
a thousand pounds but I'm going to keep it on
account for you and you say okay fine okay you've
got this account one thousand pounds and of course
I can just write that account and say you simran
1 000 pounds it's on the account I've just created
money but as soon as you take the money out I
have to give it to you you see what I'm saying
I haven't actually created any money all I've
said is if you want the money you can have it so
I I hopefully that captures the situation here
the only people you can actually create money
of the Central Bank the only way
they inject that into the system
is by making loans that means that within the
economy money always balances perfectly debt
by anyone including central banks including
individuals can make loans and when loans
are made that means essentially many people
are accessing the same money I'm saying like
I've got a thousand pounds but if you want to
use it you can use it we can both use the same
thousand pounds but it doesn't take that balance
out of the system money is always equal to debt so
that raises a question right if central banks
can only lend money they can't give money
then who can give money into the economy
and the answer is really anybody can give
money into the economy if I borrow
money from you and then give it away
then I'm in debt and since you know that
debt equals money if I go into debt then
the rest of the system has positive money
you see what I'm saying that makes sense but
what the power the government has is they can
borrow enormous amounts of money and give it up
and then what that does is it in a sense
puts the rest of the system out of balance
it means that the rest of the system
is suddenly no longer adding up to zero
so since the beginning of Covid the government
has increased its debt by £700 billion pound!
and since we know that the system as a whole debt
always equals total money we know that the rest
of the individuals in the game have have that 700
billion pounds they must have 700 billion pounds
so we know that the average UK adult because it's
about 50 million UK adults must have an extra
fourteen thousand pounds since the beginning
of Covid we know these things with certainty
and it's just a question of who has that money
it's just a question of who has that money so
then this sort of brings us onto other questionslike
what is QE? what does the Central Bank do? Ithink
we'll go into it in future videos but tosummarise
at its heart money is a loan from the centralbank
and then that circulates throughoutthe economy
some people go into debt whichmeans other
people go into credit, the totalamount of debt
always equals the total amountof credit
so we know for example the average UKadult
has.. was it 30 000 pounds of Mortgage Debt?
yeah, we did that in the debt video, so we
know that the average UK adult must have
£30,000 of mortgage credit, we know thatthe
government has increased its debt by £14,000
£14,000 per adult so we knowthe average UK
adult has increased their credit by £14,000
and hopefully I'm communicating thatthere
are these two different conceptions of money
one of which includes all debt, includes
all credit and always adds up to zero
and one of which is about total amount of loans
in the system they're both important if there are
loads and loads of loans in the system, what
happens is the interest rate will fall but it's
not the same as the government going into debt
and giving huge amounts of money out basically
the central bank can lend money and that brings
interest rates down but the government can give
money and that causes cash accumulation amongst
individuals since the beginning of Covid-19the
government has increases that by £700 billion we
know that cash has accumulated amongst individuals
um it's not the same as QE right there's two
things happening here QE is another form of
Central Bank lending it's more loans in the
system I think we'll do that in the next video QE
this 700 billion pounds is not QE, this is the
total amount of government debt accumulated
since Covid, it's money that the government
has either printed or borrowed and given out
but either way if I print money and give it to you
you have more money if I borrow money from you and
give it to you you have more money because money
and money owed to you are very similar things
if I borrow money give it back to you have
the money and you have the money owed to you
so did you think that's clear? *yeah* so I think
that's this is the key thing I want people to
understand um money is it's a balanced
system it's really it's a balance point
system we know it some people are in debt some
people are are in credit if you have mortgagedebt
somebody has credit, if the government
is in debt somebody has credit and it's a
system of owes money to who and of course the
people who are in debt constantly need to find
ways to get that money from the people who are in
credit otherwise they can't pay their debts back
so really it's a points-based system it's
perfectly balanced throughout Society
but the problem is in many cases it is a small
amount of very wealth people who are on credit
and it's the government and a large amount of
mortgage holding individuals who are in debt so
it creates an imbalance and the people who are
in debt such as the government which means the
taxpayer and families who have mortgages have
to constantly find money to pay to the rich
but that's it money is a balanced system, comes
from the central bank, commercial banks they can't
create money but they can create loans and if
you create loans it in some sense it seems like
more money being made because people have money
even though they have debt against it have access
to money um but crucially what is most important
for this channel for the message of this channel
that's 700 billion pounds is the increase
in government debt which means we know
there has been an increase in privateholding of
money to the extent of £14,000for every adult
in the country, whichis increasing
in most cases that money is sitting
in the bank accounts of wealthy individuals
which means your average wealth individual
has accumulated £100,000-£200,000
extra cashsince the beginning of Covid
this is not per household, it's per adult right so it
reallyis a huge amount of money and it's... this
is not money they've borrowed it's money they've
essentially been given ultimately from government
and this is how it was very easy to predict at
the very beginning of Covid that there would be
a massive increase in in asset prices and
I think what's quite interesting is now so
we're filming this in the in the middle of January
last week both the gold price and the stock price
the FTSE-100 (UK share index) came within
1% of a new all-time high and that's interesting
because economists and traders will normally say
gold goes up when the economy is weak and stocks
go up when the economy is strong but both of these
things have gone up massively and I predicted this
at the beginning of Covid and in my opinion the
reason for that is the government has given out
a huge amount of money that has ended up
beingheld by rich individuals.. it's hundreds of
thousands of pounds for every rich individual they
tend to buy assets you know they buy all kinds of
assets they'll buy stocks and property and gold
so all asset prices go up doesn't matter whether
the economy is bad or good; simply because these
guys have so much money, the flip side of it is
the government is in a huge amount of debt, partially
that's QE funded we'll do that in the next video
but they have to pay interest to the rich every
single month and for that reason that is why
they're saying we can't afford to do things and
both of these things have consequences the debt
of the government hurts public services and
it hurts public sector pay creates austerity
but the credit of the rich pushes up asset
prices and it pushes up other prices too
um this relates to the thing we said at the very
beginning of this video which is money is not real
resources so ultimately money is a token that
you use to buy real resources so if these guys
the rich have a ton of money now they're going to
buy more stuff they're going to push the price up
and you the ordinary person of this country will
get less stuff so um this amount of money
£700 billion is unbelievably large, from the very
beginning of Covid I've said it will overwhelm
basically all other economic effects until it is
resolved, it won't be resolved, it doesn't look it's
going to be resolved, so the end result is prices
will will stay high they won't come back down
especially asset prices will continue to rise
and living stands will continue to fall so
that's the video what is money a little
bit complicated but it's something that's
important for people to understand if they want
to understand what's happening with the economy
we're going to do more explanatory
videos but the key message here is
the government has gone enormously into debt that
means somebody has increased their money holding
my analysis says it's overwhelmingly the rich
that increases inequality that increases asset
prices and price in the shops and itdecreases
living standards for ordinary people
okay so there's one point I want to add on
money which I think is very important for
people to understand which is I think one common
incorrect way that people conceptualise money
is they think about as if it is a finite resource
so imagine I had like a pile of firewood okay and
then I burned the firewood bit by bit over the
course of a month and there's no firewood left
and then there's no fire but we need to go get
some more firewood people think about money as
if it's like that, because on the perspective
of an individual it kind of is like that ifyou
spend all your money then money, money runs
out but and then for example during covid the
government spent a lot of money so then this is
kind of perceptional the government spent a lot
of money we've run out of firewood we all need to
be poor now, there's nothing we can do, but money
always adds up to zero, always adds up to zero,
moneyfrom perspective of society cannot run out
it can only pass from person to
person it can only be held so
if the government has accumulated a huge
amount of debt all that means is some
other group of society has gotten rich and it
doesn't mean that we as a society have lost
our resources it's very very important to
understand that money is not real resources
money is I think I described in another video as a
competitive resource or a distributional resource
money is only used to determine who gets the real
resources and if you have lost a load of money
that can only be because somebody else has gotten
a load of money because we know with guaranteed
certainty the total amount adds up to zero and I
think this idea that money we've run out of money
I mean it was it's really powerful in politics you
know the big thing is after 2010 when the labour
government was voted out and the conservative
government was voted in there's this we've
run out of money because there's no more money
there's no more money and it's totally impossible
and because money is only a distributional
resource we know that if a problem can be
fixed by distribution of money we know that that
problem can only been a distributional problem
you cannot fix a lack of resources with
money it's not possible because money is
not resources and money cannot create resources
if you have if you don't have enough energy you
need to go and get some more energy you know
you need to get some more coal or some more
wind power or some more firewood whatever you're
using for energy you can't make out of money
um but I think this is It's been used powerfully
against the labour party I think they've said
you know "they spent all the money" but it's actually
quite powerful to understand that money can never
run out; resources can run out and you know
there may be instances you know for example
this year just gone we've seen there's been
less energy and the energy price has goneup
resources can run out but money can neverrun
out the government can never run out ofmoney
if the government has run out of money, somebody
has that money, if the government hasgone into debt
somebody has that debt there, it's really
important to understand money.. you as an
individual can run out of money but society can
never run out of money and if the government has
gone into debt it is because somebody has
accumulated money; it's always in balance
money currently is flowing from the government
to the rich leaving government with big powers
of debt and the rich would be part
of money there's one other thing
they can do with that mass amount of
income they can buy your mom's house